ahora que ya tenemos un entendimiento
acerca de la tabla periódica y los
átomos en ella empecemos a trabajar con
las moléculas y compuestos vamos a
necesitar una forma de representar las
moléculas y para eso existen las
fórmulas existen dos bueno en realidad
tres maneras importantes para
representar las una es la fórmula
molecular
fórmula
moléculas
y la otra es la fórmula empírica lo
escribiré de otro color para que se
entienda
fórmula
empírica
y la diferencia bueno hablemos sobre qué
significa la palabra empírico cuando
empezaba a tomar mis cursos de química
el profesor capturo nuestra atención con
esta palabra ya no recuerdo el
significado exacto pero quiere decir
lograr a través de la observación o
experimento o también basado en la
experiencia entonces si alguien les dice
que resolvió tal o cual problema
empíricamente se refiere que lo resolvió
a través de un experimento o de su
observación por otro lado la fórmula
molecular esencialmente es el número de
átomos de una molécula ahorita les
enseño de qué se trata entonces la
fórmula empírica nos dice que es lo que
otras personas observaron mucho antes
incluso de que se conocieran los átomos
lo que ellos observaron era la
proporción de los átomos entre ellos sin
saber qué número de átomos había déjenme
mostrarles a qué me refiero
y yo les dijera déjenme ver pensé no la
fórmula molecular del benceno es de 6
átomos de carbono c 6
y 6 átomos de hidrógeno
h 6 pero si fuéramos químicos de los
años 90 y no supiéramos sobre el número
de átomos pero tenemos una gran bolsa de
benceno y queremos medir la proporción
que existe del carbono al hidrógeno
encontraríamos que por cada carbono hay
un hidrógeno entonces la fórmula
empírica es ce h como somos en los años
90 y no sabemos que en realidad tenemos
6 de estos pero sabemos que por cada
carbono hay también un hidrógeno hay una
manera muy fácil de pasar de la fórmula
molecular a la fórmula empírica solo
tenemos que encontrar el máximo común
divisor del número de átomos en la
molécula en este caso es 6 y 6 entonces
obviamente 6 si dividimos ambos lados en
36 obtenemos la fórmula empírica
es imposible pasar de la fórmula
empírica a la fórmula molecular pues nos
falta información no sabemos si esto es
106 h 6 o c2 h 2 simplemente no sabemos
al principio del vídeo les mencioné que
hay tres formas de representar a las
moléculas y la tercera es la fórmula
estructural lo usaremos muy seguido
incluso ya lo hemos usado les mostraré
la fórmula estructural del benceno nos
dirá cómo están acomodados los átomos y
el benceno en particular es muy
interesante se ve como algo así
trataré de dibujar
esto lo verán mucho en química orgánica
el benceno parece como un hexágono donde
los vértices son los átomos de carbono
los pondré en otro color
este es carbono carbono carbono carbono
carbono carbón tienen dobles enlaces
doble enlace
y luego hay enlaces simples con el
hidrógeno
pondré el hidrógeno en otro color
hidrógeno nitrógeno hidrógeno
hidrógeno y obviamente la fórmula
estructural nos da mucha información por
ejemplo podemos pensar en cómo esta
molécula interactúa con otras mientras
que la fórmula molecular solo nos dice
que hay en la molécula y la fórmula
empírica nos da muy poca información
solo nos dice la proporción de
diferentes átomos en la molécula
esta es la fórmula
estructural
hagamos más ejemplos qué les parece si
trabajamos con agua creo que saben cuál
es la fórmula molecular para el agua
h2o
ahora queremos saber la fórmula empírica
necesitamos conocer la proporción
entonces podemos decir que por cada
oxígeno hay dos hidrógenos o que por
cada hidrógeno hay medio oxígeno la
mejor forma de reducir esto tenemos h2o
uno entonces cuál es el máximo común
divisor entre 2 y 1
hay que dividir esto entre 1 para el
caso del agua la fórmula molecular y la
fórmula empírica son iguales
h2o
y qué me dicen del azufre un ejemplo muy
interesante porque obviamente es solo
una molécula su fórmula molecular es ese
8 tiene una forma como de octagon
formado por cadenas de azufre yo no lo
voy a dibujar pero si quieren ustedes
pueden buscarlo en algún libro o en
internet
su fórmula empírica si tuviéramos una
bolsa de azufre no sabríamos que cada
átomo tiene 8 azufre y sólo sabemos que
tenemos una gran bolsa de azufre
entonces en la fórmula empírica hay un
solo átomo de esta molécula pues
dividimos entre 8 y nos queda es
únicamente sabríamos que tenemos azufre
hagamos un ejemplo más glucosa
la fórmula molecular de la glucosa es de
6 h 12 ó 6 entonces tenemos que por cada
6 carbonos hay 12 hidrógenos y 6
oxígenos si queremos reducir esto a su
fórmula empírica que nos queda
veamos si dividimos todos estos números
entre 6
nos queda un carbono dos hidrógenos y un
oxígeno esta es la proporción que existe
en una gran bolsa de esta sustancia y
esto nos dice el número exacto de átomos
en esa molécula hasta aquí es suficiente
de ejercicios ahora ya sabemos un poco
sobre fórmula molecular fórmula empírica
y fórmula estructural veamos si podemos
llevar esto un poco más allá ahora que
ya sabemos sobre fórmulas y sobre la
tabla periódica podemos conocer sobre la
composición la composición porcentual en
masa de alguna de estas moléculas lo
primero que hay que saber es cómo
obtener la masa molecular
massa
molecular
aquí abajo tengo la tabla periódica
porque la vamos a necesitar
la masa molecular está relacionada con
el número de átomos entonces si queremos
saber cuál es la masa de una molécula
digamos de una molécula de benceno cual
es la masa de una molécula de benceno lo
que hay que hacer es sumar las masas
moleculares de cada elemento que
conforme a la molécula en este caso
tenemos 6 carbonos y 6 hidrógenos lo
escribiré nuevamente de este lado
pensé en está compuesto por 6 carbonos y
6 hidrógenos ahora cuál es la masa del
carbono vamos a buscar en la tabla
periódica esta tabla la he sacado de la
pagina chemistry punto about.com de todo
el mens team aunque la encontré en el
buscador de imágenes de google veamos
anteriormente sólo habíamos visto los
números atómicos pero ahora ya nos
interesa conocer la masa atómica de cada
elemento para así poder saber la
composición en masa de diferentes
compuestos recuerden la masa atómica es
el número de protones más el número de
neutrones en el caso de carbono tenemos
6 protones más 6 neutrones que nos da
aproximadamente una masa de 12.01
también recuerden que esto es un
promedio de masa de todos los isótopos
de carbono que se han encontrado
se ha encontrado del carbono-14 por
ejemplo pero la mayoría de los carbonos
son 12 por eso se dice que tiene una
masa aproximada de 12 puntos 0 1
entonces el carbono tiene 12 unidades de
masa atómica
y cuando hablamos de las unidades de
masa atómica estamos hablando de una
fracción muy pequeñita de un gramo y
mucho más pequeñita de un kilogramo
quizá les abre un poco más de eso en el
siguiente vídeo
entonces el carbono tiene 12 unidades
demás atómicas y que hay del hidrógeno
bueno si vemos en la tabla periódica
el hidrógeno está aquí de color amarillo
y esto es muy interesante porque su
número atómico es 1 y su masa atómica es
1.007 9 que en algunas tablas periódicas
lo redondean a 1.008 esto quiere decir
que en la mayor parte del planeta el
hidrógeno tiene una masa atómica de 1 lo
que significa que prácticamente no tiene
neutrones el hidrógeno es prácticamente
un núcleo conformado por un solo protón
si quisiéramos guionizar un átomo de
hidrógeno es decir quitarle todos los
electrones que nos quedaría un solo
protón casi casi lo mismo que antes de
ion izarlo por eso es muy interesante
porque el hidrógeno es verdaderamente
simple pero entonces el hidrógeno tiene
una masa atómica de 1
si tuviera neutrones quizá tendría una
masa de al menos 2 pero el hidrógeno
tiene una masa atómica de 1 entonces
cuál es la masa de una molécula de
benceno bueno su masa es de 6 veces por
la masa del carbono que es 12
seis veces por la masa del hidrógeno que
es 16 por 12 es 72 + 6 por 1 es 6 esto
es igual a 78 ahora qué pasaría si
alguien nos preguntara hoy qué
porcentaje de benceno es carbón bueno
nosotros le diríamos la parte que
corresponde al carbono la parte del
carbono en benceno es esta 72 unidades
de masa atómica
eso es carbón y para saber qué
porcentaje es en el benceno solo hay que
dividir 72 entre 78 ya que 78 es la masa
total 72
/ 78
esto es igual a 90 y 2.3 por ciento
entonces el 90 y 2.3 por ciento del
benceno es carbón y claro el 7.7 por
ciento es hidrógeno hagamos lo mismo
para algunas de estas otras moléculas
digamos que queremos saber cuál es la
masa de una molécula de agua hay mucha
agua en el planeta seguro que saben que
es y ya sabemos que la masa atómica del
hidrógeno es 1 una unidad de masa
atómica
y cuál es la masa del oxígeno bueno la
masa del oxígeno es 15.999 4 que lo
podemos redondear a 16 esto quiere decir
que la mayor parte del planeta en un
átomo de oxígeno hay 8 protones y casi 8
neutrones entonces la masa del oxígeno
es de 16 unidades de masa atómica
la masa total de la molécula es tenemos
dos hidrógenos por la masa del hidrógeno
que es 1
un oxígeno por su masa que es de 16 esto
es igual a 18 unidades de masa atómica
para el agua y ahora yo les pregunto qué
porcentaje de esa masa es oxígeno bueno
simplemente dividimos 16 entre 18 verdad
usemos nuevamente la calculadora 16
entre 18 es igual a 80 y 8.888 vamos a
redondear loa 88.9 por 180 y 8.9 por
ciento del agua es oxígeno observen esto
aún cuando hay dos hidrógenos en la
fórmula dos hidrógenos por cada oxígeno
la masa del oxígeno es mucho más grande
es 16 veces más grande que la masa del
hidrógeno por eso la mayor parte del
agua es oxígeno
en el siguiente vídeo les hablaré sobre
cómo encontrar en un problema en el que
solo nos dan la composición de alguna
sustancia
la fórmula empírica pero antes de acabar
con este vídeo les quiero mencionar
algunas cosas importantes el otro día
estuve investigando sobre metales porque
me interesa mucho saber por qué algunos
son más conductores que otros y en
algunas páginas web
bueno aquí estoy refiriéndome a los
metales de transición que tienen llenos
sus orbitales de en algunos lugares
mencionan a estos como metales y a estos
elementos como metales de transición y
yo dije órale esto está bien confuso
porque yo considero al hierro al cobre
el oro y la plata más metálicos que nada
porque deben llamarse metales de
transición y estos en color rosa pues
son metales también pero se les puede
llamar metaloides y estos del grupo p
todos se consideran semiconductores
semi
conductores
a mayor grado son más dúctiles y tienen
menores puntos de fusión entonces aunque
son metales los verdaderos metales están
acá los azules porque cuando pensamos en
la naturaleza metálica que en química se
habla mucho de eso quien donará más
electrones que los elementos de aquí esa
es su naturaleza atómica mientras que
estos si donan sus electrones pero mucho
menos ellos son los más electro
negativos les gusta conservar más sus
electrones para ellos mismos y no son
muy buenos compartiendo por eso se les
llama
semiconductores pero bueno sólo quería
mencionar celos porque hay mucho debate
sobre cómo deberían llamarse estos
elementos si buscan en diferentes tablas
periódicas algunos llaman a estos como
metales
otros como metaloides o semiconductores
pero yo sólo quería mencionarlo para que
sepan de qué se trata todo esto para mí
es más claro si les llamó a estos
semiconductores porque son naturales
metallica es menor que la de estos de
aquí hasta el próximo vídeo